como una señal de victoria o de
escepticismo frente al cob y 19 el
presidente de donald trump se quitó la
mascarilla tras llegar a la casa blanca
pese a que todavía no está fuera de
peligro según dijeron sus médicos
aprendí mucho acerca del cura virus y
una cosa es segura no dejen que los
domine no le tengan miedo van a vencer
y ahora estoy mejor y quizás soy inmune
el mandatario publicó este mensaje en su
cuenta de twitter y aquí se ve como
interactúo con un grupo de personas
durante varios minutos para producir el
vídeo mientras permanecía sin mascarilla
la actitud de trump calificada de
irresponsable se ha dejado ver
repetidamente en esta oportunidad instó
a sus ciudadanos a salir a las calles y
el domingo dejo brevemente el hospital
walter reed para saludar a sus
seguidores
requena resuelva no se puede engañar
sobre ciertas cosas y no digo que lo
hayan hecho si de hecho el presidente
había realmente contraído el virus y lo
sabía antes de salir en público ya sabes
los encuentros y no llevaba una
mascarilla eso es otra cosa
cualquiera que contraiga el virus
diciendo que las mascarillas no importan
que el distanciamiento no importa creo
que es responsable de lo que les pasa
que es con este comportamiento trump
llega a una casa blanca donde el virus
sigue propagándose principalmente entre
quienes asistieron a la ceremonia de
nominación de la jueza emmy con ibarra a
la corte suprema- los casos más
recientes fueron la secretaria de prensa
del presidente y dos de sus asistentes
eeuu ya superó las 210 mil muertes por
kobe 19 y el número de contagios se
acerca a los 7 millones y medio